suffice to say our politicians are too
old but don't count on any of our
geriatric leaders to step aside anytime
soon President Biden wants to be in
office until he's 86 despite a bombshell
book claiming Joe privately admits to
AIDS that he is tired and keeps his
schedule clear before 10 a.m we learned
that 90 year old Senator Dianne
Feinstein has reportedly given power of
attorney to her daughter after a series
of hospitalizations and this week Senate
minority leader Mitch McConnell appears
to freeze for an extended period of time
but the Capital Physician medically
cleared him to go back to work the GOP
candidate Nikki Haley thinks it's time
for a change
we need to start getting new faces new
voices younger Generations involved in
our government and we need to have
everybody else understand when it's time
to go it's sad no one should feel good
about seeing that you know with any more
than we should feel good about seeing
Dianne Feinstein any more than we should
feel good about a lot of what's
happening or seeing Joe Biden's decline
what I will say is right now the Senate
is the most privileged Nursing Home in
the country I mean you know Mitch
McConnell has done some great things and
he deserves credit but you have to know
when to leave
so um you know obviously uh Nikki Haley
is right about this uh we do seem to
have a bit of a problem uh and uh with
our our the age of our leaders
um but I don't know that I agree with
her entirely on her Solutions but uh
judge you know we saw a couple of times
in the last couple of weeks where Mitch
has to be unplugged and replugged back
in what do you make of this well
first of all I find it stunning that uh
the whole time Donald Trump was
president and people were yelling the
25th Amendment let's get him out then 20
for the minute you know Joe Biden whose
cognitive decline is so apparent to all
of us the Limited hours the way he even
got into office but I'll tell you one of
the things that I that I take from this
is that these people there are two
things there's a difference between age
and confidence who whoever was sitting
here
um oh it was peers talking about the
fact that Mick Jagger is 80 and can get
on a stage Dance for two hours and do it
again the next night and be sharp as
attack okay so it's not about age alone
and there is some benefit to
institutional knowledge there is some
benefit to wisdom let's not just throw
that off the table but one of the things
that I found was so important that when
you have positions of power whether it
be you know for me I was a district
attorney okay you're in charge of the
grand jury who gets indicted when you're
a judge you decide whose civil liberties
are violated whose or not okay that
power is rented power you do not own it
you are not that person and when you
leave you understand that you are no
longer that person these people are
selfish they are selfish they are
egotistical they believe that they
should be in power for as long as they
want when they're making fools of
themselves and honestly Dianne Feinstein
couldn't answer a question uh uh that
was an obvious question as to whether or
not she voted on something that she
couldn't vote right Joe Biden didn't
remember he was in Ireland when a
seven-year-old remembered it you know
this is dangerous for the country but my
point that I just want to leave everyone
with is every minute that they are in
power right now is a reflection of their
ego and their selfishness uh Jesse uh
one of the things that Nikki Haley talks
about is a cognitive test
um and I I you know obviously it's a
problem and we need to figure out how to
do something about it but the whole idea
of the government uh conducting
cognitive tests for politicians before
they allow them to run for office kind
of blows me away because I don't really
know who's going to conduct the test
who's going to grade the test I mean is
that the right no Charlie they're going
to cheat on the test
who's gonna make sure they don't cheat
No One's Gonna Make sure they don't
cheat everyone's gonna pass and Nikki is
not making any friends in the Senate
when she calls it a nursing home I don't
know if that was the best line but
people don't age overnight
it's not like all of a sudden Diane got
old every six years everybody in
California says I want Diane I want
Diane and they've been doing it for
decades same with Joe Biden we knew how
old he was we knew how old Bernie was
how old all these people are we keep
putting them in office
the thing is is that you don't really
vote for the politician you vote for the
people behind the politician you've seen
fetterman's chief of staff is really the
senator you've seen the person whisper
into Diane feinsteins just just vote Yes
just just vote Yes Biden the same way
remember what was her name binder who
came out and said when I ran for office
basically made a mistake and it made it
obvious that she's writing his tweets
and same with Feinstein all of these
Chiefs of Staff they're the real power
so it's not that hard to be a politician
and that's the real answer here you got
to just say what 51 of the country or
the voters want you have to ask for
money and you have to maybe ask a few
questions in a hearing and half of those
questions the staff is just putting the
question in front of you and you read it
it's really not that hard
so uh Richard I think uh judge is right
about this I mean the arrogance of it is
kind of Staggering and it's like
honestly do you really think that you're
the only person who can do this job that
there isn't somebody who's south of 80
that might be able to do the job but I
think Jesse brings up a good point and
it's the right point right think about
this case of minority leader Mitch
McConnell every six years the people of
Kentucky reelect them and then they
re-elect them again and they re-elect
them again without consideration of his
age or anything and so I think that goes
to the point it's ultimately up to the
voters of this country the voters of
their District the voters of their state
to make that determination of whether or
not they want to elect them but I do
think it's important to realize if you
look at the country and why I think you
see a general it's that dissatisfaction
for our elected officials no matter what
party you're in is because if you look
look at the age distribution right
there's 21 Millennials in this country
there's one Millennial Senator there are
20 gen zeers in this country there's
zero senators and one member of the
House of Representative the average age
of the the United States Senate is 64
years old that's why people are
generally dissatisfied they don't see
themselves represented in government no
matter your age no matter your race no
matter your anything you don't see
yourself represented in government and
that's what people indeed find
problematic well the good news for aging
folks is that Joe Biden is negotiating
prescription drugs to make them lower
for them well there's look there's a big
difference the reason why people are
older when they go into politics is
because they typically go in after
they've had a career and they've had a
family and they're not flying back and
forth to Washington DC I mean there are
reasons why people are older and there
is something to be said about some kind
of experience I've been in DC long
enough to know the difference between
offices whose staff are just running the
show and offices where the senator or
the congressman is in full command of
what they're doing every day and most of
them allow their staffers to do all the
work it is undemocratic because people
are voting for a representative they're
not voting for their staff and yet here
we are in this position but when it
comes to the playing field for elections
and the argument that this happens every
six years over 2 years of the house
it's not even playing field when it
comes to incumbency I mean if you are a
senator for 30 years you have all the
the infrastructure you have all the
money I mean it's not easy for someone
to come in and go up against someone
who's been in office so I'm not sure
that's
the right argument to make finally I'll
just say that for Joe Biden to be saying
no he doesn't start thanks till 10 a.m I
hope nothing bad happens before 10 a.m I
mean honestly it puts the country in
such a vulnerable position to have a
president who can't handle getting
through the day I mean what if something
really serious forget the 4 a.m phone
call at 10 A.M the 9 A.M I mean really
toast how is that not a big red flag for
the country and the rest of the world to
me I think one of the biggest issues is
term limits how do we get term limits
fast they have to vote on it I mean it's
it's we're in a catch-22 with respect to
that and that's the biggest problem well
of course I would argue that we have
term limits in the form of Elections but
the real problem but the real problem if
you ask me is that when you create a
government that is this powerful that
takes this much of your money and
redistributes it however they want to do
no one is ever going to want to give up
those seats and and then you have people
like Joe Biden who go into the uh into
this line of work to make a fortune for
themselves when insider trading is legal
in Congress yes why ever leave
right it's true hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else